When you think about the greatest inventors
of all time, there are a few names that come to
mind. Henry Ford. The Wright brothers. Thomas Edison.
But there's one name that is not as recognizable.
When you plug your phone in, turn on the
lights, or use the refrigerator, you have
Nikola Tesla to thank. This is the story of the
forgotten genius and the story begins at the end.
On January 7, 1943 a maid working at the New
Yorker Hotel walked into room 3327, where she
found the body of an 86--year-old man who
called the hotel home for the past decade.
Tesla died alone and broke. He lived off a diet
of warm milk and crackers and was obsessed with
feeding the pigeons outside. One of the greatest
inventors of all time faded into obscurity and
died penniless. There is a reason why this
happened which will become clear by the end
of this story. Tesla was born in the town of
Smiljan in present-day Croatia on July 10, 1856.
He was born during a lightning storm. According to
family legend, the midwife said halfway through the
birth: this child will be a child of darkness to
which his mother replied, no, he will be a child
of light. Little did she know how prophetic those
words would be. When Tesla was five he witnessed
his older brother fall from a horse and later
die. This would haunt him for the rest of his life.
As a child, he began seeing visions accompanied by
flashes of light, confusing what was real and what
was imaginary. This never went away. The vision
spurred his ability to conceive inventions in
his head in such detail that he didn't even need
to draw them out. He explained how the designs
were perfected in his mind in an article in 1919.
"Invariably, my device works as I conceived that
it should and the experiment comes out exactly
as I planned it. In 20 years there has not been
a single exception." Tesla credits his mom for his
interest in invention. Đuka Mandić invented small
household appliances in her spare time. She had an
eidetic memory - the ability to recall an image from
memory with high precision and she passed this on
to her son. Tesla's father was a priest and wanted
him to become one too but Tesla was interested in
engineering. When he contracted cholera as a teen
and nearly died, his father promised to send
him to engineering school if he survived and
miraculously, he did. He went to study in Austria
at the Technical College of Graz where he is
said to have worked from 3 am until 11 pm
every day. Professors were worried that he
would die from exhaustion. Tesla had a beautiful
mind. He could perform calculus in his head and
spoke eight languages. He was a good student
at the start but would not finish school.
He dropped out after becoming addicted to gambling
and cut ties with his family so they wouldn't find
out. His friends didn't know what happened to
him either. They thought he drowned in a river.
Tesla moved around Europe and eventually ended
up in Budapest working as an electrician at a
telephone company. While walking around a park
in the city one day, he had an epiphany about
developing a new way of generating electricity
using alternating current. It would be his greatest
invention that would change the world. I'll
explain more about AC a little later. In 1882,
he settled in Paris to work for the French branch
of Thomas Edison's electric company. He started off
installing indoor lighting but the managers
noticed his talents and had him doing more
complicated work, designing and building dynamos
and motors. He was soon traveling throughout Europe
fixing problems at other Edison branches. Two
years later, in 1884, Tesla's manager offered him
a job at Edison Machine Works in New York City.
He agreed and arrived in America with only four
cents in his pocket because his money was stolen
on the boat ride over. Tesla initially had a good
impression of Edison. Edison was also impressed by
Tesla, later saying: "I have had many hard-working
assistants but you take the cake." This mutual
admiration didn't last. They would become bitter
rivals. The two men disagreed over how electricity
should be contained and delivered. Edison preferred
direct current which is a system where the
electric charge only flows in one direction.
Tesla was a fan of alternating current in which
the electric charge changes direction periodically.
Changing directions is crucial to maintaining a
steady supply of electricity because it does not
overpower outlets. This means it can provide
more power and transmit power over longer
distances. It's the reason AC powers our homes
and other large appliances whereas DC powers
smaller items like flashlights. But Edison didn't
care about AC because it could have hurt the
sales of direct current since he owned all the
patents for DC. According to Tesla, a manager at
Edison's company offered him a $50,000 bonus if
he could improve some machines that ran on DC.
When he did, the manager refused to pay up. Another
account of the story has Edison telling Tesla:
"You don't understand our American humor." Regardless
of how it played out, Tesla quit and set off to
form his own electric company the following year
in 1885. But his investors showed little interest
and decided to take the company and all of
Tesla's patents which they could do because
Tesla had assigned the patents to the company in
exchange for stock which was now worthless. After
losing his company, Tesla had to take a job digging
ditches for two dollars a day just to survive. But
his fortunes would change. In 1887, Tesla invented
an induction motor that ran on alternating current.
The motor was the most efficient way to convert
electricity to mechanical power. Aversion of it
powers Tesla's vehicles which took its name from
the inventor. He patented the motor and showed it
off the following year at the American Institute
of Electrical Engineers that caught the attention
of George Westinghouse, a major player in the
electric market who realized Tesla's AC motor
might just be what he needed to complete his
alternating current system and compete against
Edison's DC system. So Tesla licensed the
patents for the AC motor to Westinghouse for
$60,000 and also received stock and
royalties. Westinghouse hired him as a consultant
for $2,000 a month which is the
equivalent of over $50,000 a month
today. The war of the currents began. Edison tried
hard to try to discredit Westinghouse and Tesla.
He secretly financed the electric chair that used
alternating current to prove how dangerous AC was.
Edison's company also publicly tortured animals
to prove its point. In 1903, they electrocuted a
circus elephant named Topsy and produced a film
about it called Electrocuting an Elephant. Despite
Edison's schemes, good things were happening for
Westinghouse and Tesla. They underbid Edison and
his newly formed company General Electric to
illuminate the World's Colombian Exposition
in Chicago in 1893. The first all-electric fair
celebrated the 400th anniversary of Christopher
Columbus's discovery of America. It was clear to
the 27 million people who attended that AC would
power the future. Their success continued when
they beat out Edison's General Electric again to
build the world's first alternating current power
plant in Niagara Falls. The hydroelectric power
station was a massive success and helped light up
Buffalo, New York. The building of the plant also
meant Tesla became a pioneer in renewable energy.
His statue can be found at Niagara Falls today.
Westinghouse and Tesla won the war of the
currents and direct current was being phased out.
But there were problems. Westinghouse's company
was running out of money and eventually went $10
million into debt. In 1897, he went to Tesla
and asked if his royalties could be reduced
in a desperate attempt to save the company. Tesla
was so compelled by compassion for his friend
that he ripped up his contract. He was grateful to
Westinghouse for believing in him when no one else
would. Tesla willingly walked away from $12 million
in royalties which in today's terms
would be worth over $300 million. Had he held on
to those royalties over time, he would have likely
become the wealthiest person on the planet and the
first person with a billion dollar net worth. That
act of compassion for his friend of tearing up his
contract saved Westinghouse. In return, Westinghouse
paid Tesla $216,000 for the rights to use as ac patents forever. This
is the equivalent of about $60 million
today. With that money, Tesla became financially
independent and set up a series of laboratories in
New York for new projects where he was visited by
the rich and famous, including his close friend and
one of the greatest American writers of all time,
Mark Twain. This was his period of many inventions.
He held over 300 patents in his lifetime.
He created an early version of neon lighting, the
tesla turbine - a bladeless turbine for vehicles.
He pioneered x-ray technology by experimenting
with radiation. This is an x-ray of his own hand.
Another stand-out invention was one of the first
remote controls. In 1898, he controlled a miniature
boat at Madison Square Garden in New York. It was
so far ahead of its time that the crowd thought
he was using magic to make it move. That would be
the ancestor to today's remote-controlled drones.
One of his most well-known inventions is the Tesla
coil - a device that can produce large amounts of
high voltage electricity. Because of the coils,
he discovered he could send and receive powerful
radio signals when they resonated at the same
frequency. Tesla was getting ready to broadcast
his first radio signal but disaster struck. A
fire destroyed his lab in 1895. He lost years
of research and equipment. Tesla didn't apply for
a patent for the radio until two years later. The
fire would be the turning point in his life that
led to a downhill spiral. At the same time that
he was working on radio, an Italian entrepreneur,
Guglielmo Marconi, was also working on the radio
in England. He tried to acquire patent rights in the
US but was turned down because it was too similar
to Tesla's. However, things changed when Marconi was
able to send the world's first transatlantic radio
message in 1901 using 17 of Tesla's patents. Edison
then threw his financial support behind Marconi.
Tesla had no problem with Marconi's achievements
but in 1904, the US Patent Office suddenly changed
its mind and awarded Marconi a patent for
the invention the radio. There has never
been a reason given for this decision but the
powerful financial backing Marconi received
could explain it. Marconi went on to win the Nobel
Prize in Physics in 1911 which was only possible
due to Tesla's work. Tesla was furious and sued
Marconi. The case dragged on in court for years and
was only settled in Tesla's favor after his death.
That radio incident negatively impacted the rest
of Tesla's career. For example, Tesla was obsessed
with bringing wireless communication to the world
and built a huge wireless transmission station in
Long Island, New York called Wardenclyffe Tower. He
imagined a world where we could send and receive
messages wirelessly. He was, again, well ahead of his
time. But financial backers did not have enough
faith in his project. They pulled out and banked
on Marconi's radio invention instead. This left
Tesla in financial ruin. He had no choice but to
abandon his dream project in 1905 and eventually
lost Wardenclyffe Tower to foreclosure. Tesla's
mental health deteriorated. He lived his last
decade in the New Yorker Hotel beginning in 1933.
Westinghouse Corporation hired him as a consultant
and paid for his room. He lived rent-free but died
in debt. So why did one of the greatest inventors
of all time fade into obscurity and die penniless?
You could say T esla was unlucky at times like
when the fire burned down his New York lab.
But the main reason is because Tesla was not
a capitalist. He made decisions that those with
more business acumen would not have made such as
giving up his royalties for the AC motor. He wasn't
concerned about money. He was concerned about the
pursuit of science for the betterment of humanity.
He wanted to change the world and he did. Thanks
in part to Elon Musk's company, people are starting
to learn more about the man who inspired
the company, a man whose inventions would
power our entire planet. It's because of Tesla
that modern society functions the way it does.
Tesla's mother called him a child of light
and she was quite right.
Thanks for watching the story of Nikola Tesla, I hope you
enjoyed it.
I'm Cindy Pom. If you like what you, saw subscribe to my new channel.
I also started aPatreon where you can make a monthly contribution and this will go a really long way toward helping this channel grow. See you soon.